das jahr 2020 stellt für apokalyptischen
science fiction ist schon eine beinharte
konkurrenz da ein killervirus will dann
muss sie muss die menschheit ausrotten
kilo essen überfallen die usa und die eu
wollen die menschheit mit hochenergie
laser waffen unterjochen
die irdische anführer recep tayyip
erdogan
wie von der letzten sache hast du noch
nichts mitbekommen
dann bist du in diesem video genau
richtig denn am vierten august 2009 10
kam es zum ersten mal in einem krieg zum
realen kampf mit laserwaffen bolt das
erste oft ein laser krieg war eine
logische kampfdrohne aus chinesischer
herstellung vom typ windeln o2 ein ganz
schöner ochi zehn meter lang bis zu 370
kilometer schnell und mit bis zu zwölf
laser geführten bomben oder raketen
bestückt und wer hat sie abgeschossen
der war es die schweiz war ganz bestimmt
nicht aber rational waren ist die
hochmodernen israel defense forces die
us-luftwaffe russland oder das
aufstrebende china
nein ganz daneben es war die türkei so
und isst du dich natürlich wie kann die
türkei über derart technologisch hoch
entwickelte waffen verfügen high tech
waffen die auch noch derart ausgereift
sind dass sie diese als erster
erfolgreich im kampf einsetzen konnten
immerhin ein kunststück das wäre den usa
nach russland noch china bislang
gelungen ist also als einzige erklärung
bleibt eigentlich nur übrig sie haben
sie von den außerirdischen echsen
menschen bekommen und mal gesagt habe
hört lässt dass dieses video löschen
oder etwa doch nicht nur keine angst in
diesen weg werden wir euch verraten was
es mit diesen türkischen laserwaffen auf
sich hat kleine spoiler die reptilien
waren es diesmal nicht es gibt eine
vollkommen logische erklärung ganz ohne
außerirdische die aber dennoch keine
spannung vermissen lässt denn am ende
dieses videos wirst du verstehen wodurch
laserwaffen so mächtig sind warum sie
die kriegsführung allgemein ganz schön
durcheinanderwirbeln könnten und warum
ausgerechnet die türken sie als erstes
eingesetzt haben also bist du bereits
dann mal los
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im jahr 2020 stellen sich viele die
frage wozu brauchen wir denn alles was
in den abendnachrichten kommt schlimmer
klingt als ein endzeit von moody aus
hollywood was mussten wir nicht alles
ertragen
die quellen eines killervirus killer
hornissen china schlug von com und bruce
willis verkleidet sich als dr
kostet ja und wem das nicht genug war
wir bringen euch jetzt noch den laser
krieg wird und aus hunderten von scifi
movies und jetzt die neue normalität gut
ich weiß du hast du es gestaltet die
zukunft ist jetzt und es ist keine
rosige zukunft aber ist butter bei die
fische
warum gerade laserkanonen welche
vorteile haben sie gegenüber sagen wir
mal ganz normalen raketen nun ziemlich
viel zum einen ist ein laserstrahl sehr
sehr schnell so schnell wir nicht eben
und schneller als licht geht's nimmer
das bedeutet das ist praktisch unmöglich
ist auszuweichen so war die türken dann
laserstrahlung der lage eine sich sehr
schnell bewegende drohne mit absoluter
präzision zur strecke zu bringen und
eines können wir dir versichern
diese drohne war erst der anfang
hochenergie laser können nämlich noch
viel größerer objekte zur strecke
bringen
ok und wenn du dich nur fragst wie diese
laserstrahlen eigentlich erzeugt werden
dann mal aufgepasst wir werden nachher
einen kurzen abstecher in die konten zu
sieg machen und zwar mit hilfe des
berühmten physik youtube aus spanien kw
santa pola ja fast so spanisch verstehst
kannst du auch mal einen blick auf
seinen kanal werfen hier kommt der link
und vielleicht weißt du nicht ganz weg
ist er gehört zu jedem wissenschaftlern
die das explosion entdeckt haben das
heißt erzählt unter physikern zur
allererste sahne
bevor wir euch aber mit graffitis wissen
beglücken müssen wir doch noch kurs über
politik reden denn freunde die
politische seite dieser geschichte mit
dem protagonisten türkei dem enfant
terrible der nato ist ganz schön
interessant stellt ihr nachfolgendes
kurz vor die nato als schule in einem
kinofilm aus den 80ern welche rolle
würde darin die türkei gespielt
natürlich die das schuljahr brauchen der
sein ego immer damit auch per
denn muss dass er sich mit allen auf dem
schulhof prügelt vornehmlich natürlich
griechenland das ja ebenfalls nato
mitglied ist ja und jetzt hat die türkei
sogar ihren langjährigen
hauptlieferanten die usa ziemlich
verärgert da sie aus dem arsenal der
verfeindeten schule gemacht hat
die türkei sagt sie habe russische es
400 raketen gekauft um sie zu benutzen
nicht um sie zu lagern so unbedeutend
diese nachricht auf den ersten blick
erscheinen mag sie ist sehr sehr wichtig
schließlich bis russland ein
gegenspieler der nato wir von visual
politik haben letztes jahr
nato-generalsekretär jens stoltenberg
interviewt und einmal danach gefragt was
man von diesen widerspruch eigentlich
halten und noch die integrierte
internet- es entwertet er missverstanden
jetzt wird mal gut zu denn die türkei
hat noch mehr auf lager
sie verfügt nämlich nach der usa über
die zweitgrößte armee aller nato länder
zumindest was die zahl der soldaten
angeht aber natürlich selbst soldaten
nicht alles technologie und waffen
werden immer wichtiger und in dieser
hinsicht war die türkei noch nie eine
führende militärmacht
stell dir vor obwohl sie 80 millionen
einwohner hat beträgt ihr bip gerade mal
so viel wie das der niederlande mit 15
millionen einwohnern und deshalb ist es
ja auch so erstaunlich dass die türken
plötzlich mit hightech laserwaffen
pionierarbeit leisten und wenn du wissen
möchtest wie die türkei passt du es
geschafft hat dann lasst uns wie immer
zunächst einen blick zurück in die
geschichte werfen
[Musik]
das enfant terrible der nato schau dir
diese schöne das ist der boss boss diese
meerenge ist der einzige direkte zugang
zum mittelmeer für die russische
schwarzmeerflotte seit jahrhunderten
möchte russland diese meerenge unter
seine kontrolle bringen das wollen die
türken natürlich nicht zulassen und
damit haben wir schon mal einen guten
grund dafür dass russland und die türkei
seit jahrhunderten erzfeinde sind welche
konsequenzen hatte das im laufe der
geschichte nun während des kalten kriegs
war dies von immenser bedeutung denn
dadurch war die türkei einer der ärgsten
feinde sowjetrussland trat deswegen 1952
so schnell es ging der nato bei der die
nato war ja das militärbündnis gegen die
sowjet die nato empfinde türkei mit
offenen armen
denn sie hatte nicht nur eine sehr
grosse armee sondern auch viel
antikommunistische potenzial
[Applaus]
was war dann aber das bringt nun wie
gesagt die türkei ist das enfant
terrible und sigurd im grunde mit
niemandem besonders gut aus denn was man
auf gar keinen fall vergessen darf die
türkei hat eine lange und große
imperialistische vergangenheit das
osmanische reich beherrschte
jahrhunderte lang ein riesiges
territorien und diese imperiale
vergangenheit hat sehr viel böses blut
hinterlassen
vor allem als noch der nationalismus
dazu kamen durch die unterdrückung von
minderheiten massaker deportation und
todesmärschen vertreibungen und
zwangsumsiedlungen oder gar vollkommen
hat betroffen waren vor allem die kurden
die griechen und die armenier und wenn
du jetzt denkst diese ungewöhnliche
politik hätte die moderne türkei längst
überwunden muss ich dich leider eines
besseren belehren im jahr 1974 zb führte
die türkische armee eine
völkerrechtliche intervention auf der
insel zypern durch und die dortige
türkische minderheit vor griechische
nationalisten zu schützen sie gingen
jedoch weiter als das völkerrechtes
vorsah und besetzte einfach einen großen
teil der insel wo bei 160.000 griechen
vertrieben wurden und 1500 spurlos
verschwanden
seitdem ist die insel in zwei hälften
geteilt in der einen hälfte spricht nur
türkisch in der anderen griechischen
daher ist griechenland nicht das was gut
auf die türkei zu sprechen deswegen
sagten auch die usa in den siebziger
jahren zur türkei wir werden dich vor
den sowjets geschützten aber wir wissen
wer du bist da trauen wir nicht wir
werden dir waffen verkaufen aber nicht
unsere moderne stücke was der teufel was
du damit anstellen würde ist die türken
versuchten einige jahre eine eigene
waffe industrie aufzubauen aber so
richtig kam diese nie in fahrt oder hast
du schon mal was davon gehört dass sich
alle welt um türkische top waffen reist
nun um ihr nicht allzusehr unrecht zu
tun
ihr bemerkenswertes erzeugnis waren die
maria raketenwerfer die größten der welt
aber abgesehen davon eben nichts was der
rede wert wäre
die regierung in ankara legte ab dem
jahr 2000 dann all diesen militär
programme auf eis interessanterweise
also genau in jenen jahren in denen die
türkei einen ungeahnten wirtschafts boom
erlebte damals wurde ja sogar darüber
gesprochen ob sie der eu nicht sofort
beitreten können heute undenkbar
sie werden einen hohen preis für ihre
verraten zahlen
türkische soldaten kapitulieren auf der
bosporus brücke nachdem ihr nächtlicher
militär putsch gescheitert ist der 250
menschen das leben kostete präsident
erdogan schwört rache ganz genau mit dem
putsch gegen die türkische präsident
erdogan im jahr 2016 änderte sich alles
heute glauben viele erdogan selbst habe
den putsch gegen sich inszeniert
ebenfalls klassisches fleck operation um
sich endgültig von der politischen
gegner zu entledigen ob dies wirklich
schild oder nur eine
verschwörungstheorie ist können wir
nicht sagen was er aber genau wissen ist
dass erdogan selbst den putsch als ein
geschenk gottes bezeichnete da ihm den
perfekten vorwand bot alle seine gegner
innerhalb der armee zu liquidieren
die verfassung des landes nach seinem
gusto und zu schreiben und damit noch
mehr macht zu erlangen
seitdem scheint ist erdogans ziel zu
sein das osmanische reich wieder
herzustellen und die von atatürk
begründet dass die polarisierung der
türkei rückabwickeln zu wollen die ganze
welt soll die angst vor der türkei und
iran haben und gleichzeitig so die
türkische armee erst richtig vor erdogan
auf die knie fallen
erdogan reinigt armee und justiz nach
gescheiterten putsch
und liebe freunde das was oft
optimistisch als solche bezeichnet wird
ist in wahrheit ein massaker
unvorstellbaren ausmaßes nach dieser
säuberung blieben in der türkischen
armee gerade mal 20 piloten das heißt
die türkei hat 200 kampfflugzeuge aber
nur 20 piloten die sie fliegen können
und das ist nur ein kleines beispiel
damit du dir eine vorstellung machen
kannst dann ähnlich radikale vorgänger
spielten sich natürlich auch in allen
anderen bereichen der an er diese
gnadenlose liquidierung aller fraktionen
und menschen die nicht zu 100 prozent
aus linie sind hat eine skelett armee
hinterlassen
so jetzt fragst du dich sicher ganz
berechtigt wenn dieser mann mit diesem
rad von armee ein neues osmanisches
reich aufbauen
der schlaue erdogan versuchte zunächst
wieder einmal die usa davon zu
überzeugen ihm doch noch ein paar
moderne waffen zu verkaufen
türkei verlangt us patriot raketen um
russland in syrien abzuschrecken
aber so dumm sind die amis nun auch
wieder nicht der tour kutsche ließen
nicht lange auf sich warten
und statt neuer waffen bekannt die
türkei fordere transparent paket neuer
sanktionen verpasst und das nicht ohne
grund denn erdogan hatte wieder einmal
massaker unter der kurdischen minderheit
einer minderheit die im irak und in
syrien konflikt ein verbündeter der usa
ist
und nicht irgend ein verbündeter wie für
sich erweist haben sich die kurden
maßgeblich am kampf gegen die
terroristen von dice beteiligt die sich
selbst gerne als islamischer staat
bezeichnet haben
kurz gesagt schon würde in teufels küche
geraten wenn er diese waffenlieferungen
an der türkei erlauben und diese dann
mit us-waffen us verbündete angreifen
würde die nato will also schon wieder
einmal die türkei beschützen und
gleichzeitig verhindern dass diese über
eigene moderne waffen verfügt und diese
paradoxe situation erklärte nachrichten
wie diese spanien wartet einsatz von
luftverteidigungssysteme in der türkei
aus spanien ist ein verbündeter der
vereinigten staaten und verfügt über die
von den türken so heiß ersehnten
patriot-raketen also hat die nato
spanien befohlen einige davon zum schutz
der türkischen grenze zum iran zu
stationieren
aber wie du dir sicher vorstellen kannst
ist erdogan nicht gerade überglücklich
mit dieser lösung
er will ja seine eigenen waffen und
seine eigene militärdoktrin haben denn
schließlich ist die türkei ein wichtiger
akteur im libyen-krieg sie für ihre
eigenen bündnisse und ihre eigenen
strategien unabhängig von der nato und
das wird auch die eigene waffen ja und
genau aus diesem grund fuhr erdogan die
entwicklungspolitischen
rüstungsindustrie wieder hoch und diese
umfassen auch technologien wie diese
[Musik]
bürgschaft laserwaffen system zur
stärkung des militärs
denn laserstrahlen haben viele vorteile
sie sind eine viel versprechende
technologie zur flugabwehr und man muss
neues militärpersonal daran ausbilden
damit hat erdogan einen super vorwand um
neue ihm treu ergebnisse und daten
anzuheuern
damit hätten wir die politische frage
geklärt allerhöchste zeit denn du
wartest sicher schon auf den technischen
partner die antwort auf die frage wie
genau funktionieren diese laserwaffen
eigentlich gut dann mal los
[Musik]
laserstrahlen das neue schießpulver also
zunächst muss sich vergegenwärtigen dass
er über eine der wichtigsten erfindungen
des jahrhunderts sprechen so wichtig
dass es dafür nobelpreise nur so
handelte seit 1964 wurden für die
entwicklung und anwendung von laser fünf
nobelpreisträger ausgezeichnet und die
anwendungen sind vielfältig vom
strichcode lesegerät im supermarkt über
metall ogi medizin optik bis hin zu
waffen
dieses breite spektrum an anwendungen
verdanken laser ihren besonderen
eigenschaften und deren entdeckung
verdanken wir den begründern der
quantenmechanik also den besten musikern
aller zeiten heisenberg schrödinger
einstein klang und zunächst einmal
müssen wir uns aber vergegenwärtigen
dass der laser nichts anderes ist als
licht photon normales ganz gewöhnliches
licht wie das von der sonne oder von
deiner handy lampe aber natürlich wirst
du mit deinem handy keine drohne
abschließen können denn dazu müssen wir
mit dem licht noch etwas machen um als
laser durchzugehen muss das licht die
folgenden drei eigenschaften haben es
muss wohl chromatisch kohärent und
fokussiert sein also monochromer tisch
bedeutet dass es auf eine einzige
frequenz eine einzige farbe beschränkt
ist fokussiert bedeutet dass die
lichtstrahlen nicht auseinanderstreben
und kohärent bedeutet dass seine wellen
wie im takt marschieren nicht physiker
können sich einfach als faustformel
merken dass der laser aus sehr reinen
lichtteilchen zusammengesessen dass die
sich super duper geordnet bewegen der
unterschied zwischen einer normalen
taschenlampe und einem laserstrahl ist
die der zwischen einer bahn wurde und
einer römischen region war der 1 ist
jeder kämpfer jedes photon individuell
und auf sich allein gestellt in der
laser armee müssen wir uns genau der
soldaten in perfekt geordnete formation
vorstellen die in vollkommenem
gleichschritt marschieren synchronisiert
wie ein uhrwerk
und das alles verdanken die den quanten
eigenschaften der materie und
insbesondere der geschichten struktur
der atome die erst mit dem aufkommen der
konto mechanik verstanden werden konnten
einsteigen sah diese interessante
anwendung in seinem neuen konzept der
atome voraus ihre umsetzung in den 60er
jahren erlebt jedoch nicht mehr mit
seinen einzigartigen eigenschaften ist
der laser in der lage viel energie auf
kleinsten raum und auch in puzzle von
kurzer dauer zu konzentrieren
damit wird seine leistung vervielfacht
möglich machte dies eine revolutionäre
erfindung die sogenannte check points im
playstation zu deutsch verstärkung
gechipt
für den euro und endet 2018 den
nobelpreis erhielten in diesem verfahren
können maximale puls spitzenleistungen
im privatbereich also mehr als 10 hoch
15 watt erreicht werden oder 10 hoch 22
watt pro quadratzentimeter jetzt willst
du natürlich wissen wie viel das in
fußball feldern ist nun mal sehen ein
normales stadion flutlicht hat circa
2.000 watt um ein fußballstadion für
10.000 zuschauer zu beleuchten braucht
etwa 200 dieser flutlichter macht also
400 tausend watt pro stadion
das heißt ein cpr laser kann auf einen
quadratzentimeter so viel licht
konzentrieren wie die flutlichter von 25
milliarden fußballstadien und mit einem
hochleistungslaser wie diesen kann man
dann unter anderem eine drohne ziemlich
leicht abschießen oder eine rakete
ablenken oder ein raumschiff bis nach
alpha centauri schicken
so betreten wir eine neue ära das
zeitalter des lesers und die türkei ist
ganz vorne dabei aber sie ist natürlich
nicht das einzige land das über laser
verfügt sie waren aber die ersten diesen
echten kampf einsatz erprobt haben und
das habe ich noch nicht mal die usa
gewagt sie haben gerade mal im mai 2020
mitten in der kroner krise ihren ersten
laserwaffen test an bord eines schiffes
durchgeführt und auch china schläft
nicht und betreibt eifrig
forschungsarbeit an ihren eigenen
strahlen waffen befinden uns also gerade
an einer ganz wichtigen schwelle in der
geschichte der kriegsführung so ähnlich
wie zu der zeit hast erst nach den
anstiegen schießpulver einzusetzen und
damit viele militär strategien wasser
und verteidigungsanlagen die sich über
jahrhunderte bewährt hatten vollkommen
obsolet machten die frage an dich lautet
nun also glaubst du dass wir einer neuen
art der kriegsführung ist auge sehen
inwieweit werden laserstrahlen am ende
raketen und gewehre ersetzen und wird
erdogan am ende sein neues osmanisches
reich bekommen und sultan werden wird
ist alles was ihr dazu einfällt in den
kommentarbereich unter dieser bedingung
wir hoffen dass dieses video gefallen
hat und vielleicht auch etwas gebracht
hat was ja gib uns bitte einen daumen
hoch und unterstützt uns in denen du es
mit deinen freunden heißt und vergesst
bitte nicht dass wir jede woche neue
videos hochladen werden also fast keines
unserer updates abonniert unseren kanal
und klickt auf das klinge symbol um
rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu werden
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]